joining us right now right here on the
Rich Eisen show I'm pleased to have
right here on NBCSN because he precedes
us every single day on PFT live in the
mornings and then the PFT p.m. podcast I
will be recording later on today
his other guests are two guys named Joe
burrow and chase young Chris heard of
them Mike Florio where am I in am ii in
the in the run of show with those two
guys later on yeah we're still working
all that you know I mean I'm fragile
Mike just be very careful good to chat
with you everybody okay in your world
and your family and everybody else
everything's good everything's good I
have not left our property for 30 days
Wow and it's kind of like you get to a
point where you want to see how high the
streak will go like I'm 26 away from
DiMaggio so I really don't want to leave
now and I think the people who live in
my town prefer that I not so it's a good
trade-off well look I don't want to talk
about anymore I want to jinx it you know
what I mean like I just let's just let's
just leave that one there and just keep
doing what you're doing Mike you know
what I'm saying I know I know you start
thinking about it too much before you
know it you jump in your car and you
just take off and drive down the hill
into your head so I there's a good
chance that my car battery is dead by
now so I couldn't leave if I wanted that
I got it Mike Florio here in the Rich
Eisen show let's get into it sir
you've got Borough on Later there's no
question he's number one overall unless
you think somebody's gonna do a Yolo
Ditka trade or you're hearing anything
like that at all or this is just uh this
is just a formality
yeah here's the thing you never know
when they're telling you the truth when
they send out the smoke signals that
they're not going to trade the pic or
the Dolphins aren't going to trade up
for the pic I mean if anybody trades up
it's going to be the Dolphins right the
Dolphins have been doing their homework
on Joe burrow the Bengals have done all
their homework on Joe burrow and Brian
Flores the coach of the Dolphins can say
all he wants that they don't want to
make the investment necessary to move up
and Chris Greer the GM of the Dolphins
can say the same thing and the Bengals
can say we're not going to trade this
pick
we're using this pick and then you make
an offer to the Bengals that they can't
refuse and that they recognize they
shouldn't refuse and frankly all due
respect to the Bengals that's one of the
wildcards here will they know when
they've been given an offer that they
can't and shouldn't refuse but if Steven
Ross the owner of the Dolphins Ridge
swoops in and I've tried to think of the
most delicate way to put this but Ross
is either 80 or close to it you get the
Leon Hess dynamic at some point where
you say look in my lifetime I want to
have a franchise quarterback and we have
squandered draft picks time and again
over the course of my ownership of the
team so what if we have to throw another
pick or two onto the pile to get the
Bengals to say yes to this and if
they're doing that behind the scenes
they're not going to tell us that that's
my point it looks the same from our
perspective if it's happening or if it's
not happening so if anything happens
with Joe borough other than him going to
the Bengals it's going to be out of the
blue at some point in the next three
days a trade is done and it shocks us
just like when the Falcons moved up to
number one with the Chargers 19 years
ago to get Mike Vick well I mean just I
looked it up Steven Ross is 80 in about
three weeks time and a great reference
of the old Jets owner Leon Hess who you
know I just had flashbacks of coach
height and things like that that I need
to just get through for the moment but
you make a very valid point Mike in that
the Dolphins need to do it and do it now
in many ways but why wouldn't that still
be to a worry what are you hearing right
now and you want to talk about smokes
and screens my gosh you're either
hearing two has fallen because nobody
really believes is medical until they
can actually put their hands on them or
they're just saying all that because
they think he's as special as everybody
thought he was the minute he looked off
a safety against Georgia what do you
think about that Mike one last thing
about Barone roscas it dovetails with
the tourist stuff sure I caught wind
very early on in the process that Ross
absolutely loves and covets and wants
burrow and I heard it in a way that
passed through my BS filter because when
it comes to pre-draft rumors your BS
filter has to be extremely thick and
selectively when I started hearing for
example rich that tua is potentially
going to slide out of the top ten my
first thought was well the team that's
holding the 11th overall pick is putting
this out there because that happens if
you love a guy you put bad stuff out
there in the hope city slides down the
draft and you can draft it if you don't
like a guy you put out all sorts of good
stuff so some sucker out there picks the
guy that you don't want anyway and it
pushes someone that you do want farther
down the board but I started hearing
from way too many people that to is
going to slide out of the top ten all it
takes is one team but I've heard from
too many people he's going to slide
because the doctors employed by the
team's cannot put their hands on to a
cannot personally observe him and the
teams are concerned rich that the
doctors who are accountable to us can't
tell us everything's fine we don't care
if the doctor that has been treating to
it for the last three years says he's
fine because of course he's going to say
he's fine and there are different
definitions of what is in what isn't
fine the doctor that's been treating to
it for the last three years could
testify under oath and pass a polygraph
test that he thinks or she thinks the
Tewa is fine but the team doctors are
the ones that ultimately have their
ongoing ability to work for those teams
riding on the accuracy of their
assessments and without that ability to
check out that hip without that ability
to check out whatever else on him may
not be a hundred percent it's gonna be
hard for someone to pull the trigger and
I'll repeat what a GM told me back when
tor got hurt
three years in college football three
lower body injuries and you're talking
about a much greater degree of
physicality and roughness and you have
to assume that that trend is going to
continue when he gets the NFL for a guy
who's fairly mobile that's not a good
sign so I feel bad for him and he can't
get properly checked out ahead of time
but those are the circumstances and I
think it could result in him sliding out
of the top ten and then there's Justin
Herbert then that would move up maybe
just because of that or the the rumors
that the Dolphins like him or other
teams do like him is actually valid what
did you make of the report that the
Giants Joe judge had a chat with Herbert
what the hell is that all about well
it's simple and we've seen this happen
before
we've seen it happen with great
quarterbacks in the top five when
there's a possibility for a trade even
if the team that's holding the pick
doesn't want him the more you know about
that guy because if somebody trades up
with the Giants at number four they're
not trading up just so they can brag hey
we picked up the fourth pick in the
draft now who the hell do we take
they're coming up to get somebody and
the most likely coming up to get Justin
Herbert before the Dolphins can get him
so if it's the charters at six or the
Panthers at seven who are going to be
negotiating with the Giants the more the
Giants know about Herbert the better
suited they're gonna be rich to
negotiate in a meaningful way because
you are trading that player to the
Chargers or the Panthers you're not
trading that pic so you want to be able
to say oh hey we've studied the film and
we've talked to them and and I know he
we think he's worth more and here's why
you know ultimately it could be the
Dolphins into a flip flop four and five
just to keep the Panthers or the
Chargers from taking that fourth spot
but I think that's why the Giants are
doing what they're doing they've got
their guy in daniel Jones they're not
going to they're not going to supplant
him with a top five pick at quarterback
one year later they want to be ready
though in the event that these
negotiations happen for somebody who
wants to jump up and get Justin Herbert
and you know what the Giants may not get
the chance because maybe the Lions will
be a team that slides down for one of
these teams that would like to go get
Herbert I love it so it gives them the
ammunition to ask for more if they know
just how good the kid is we didn't know
these things there's a lot of good from
Justin Herbert I remember at one point
and you know you always hear during
college football season rich this guy is
gonna be the first overall pick that guy
was gonna be the first overall picture
but there was buzz that if Herbert had
come out after the 28th yes season he
would have been in the running for the
number one overall pick last year yeah
and that the Giants were disappointed
that he decided to stay in Oregon and
that they were sitting there second
overall they might not have taken say
qualm Barkley if Herbert was in right
then and there I heard the the same
thing now that was real right a couple
years who knows but right but there was
a time just like there was a time where
two it was regarded as the number one
overall pick for this year there was a
time where Herbert's name had bubbled up
and that's happened time and again who
would have ever dreamed that Joe burrow
was going to be the number one overall
pick a year ago Mike
Florio of pro football talk on on NBC SN
every single day preceding us and Mike
Tirico show and then of course obviously
podcast form and then at Pro Football
Talk on Twitter right here on the Rich
Eisen show Odell Beckham and Leonard
fournette both rumored to be on the
block
what's the smoke screen or real mists of
all that in your mind it's definitely
real with Leonard fournette and the
Jaguars have come to the conclusion that
from a culture standpoint they're trying
to move on with guys who are gonna fit
better with what they're trying to do
and I also think at a certain level rich
you're gonna see under Jay Gruden the
new offensive coordinator there on
offense that maybe doesn't incorporate
the downhill running style of Leonard
fournette it's going to be more of a
wide-open passing game with gardner
minshew but now they need to find
somebody who will take him for one year
4.1 million with the ability to pick up
an option for 2021 which would be eight
point four eight million for a guy that
had sixteen hundred and seventy four
yards from scrimmage last year and
there's so many people out there when
they hear Leonard fournette they like
initially make a face it's like he had
16 hundred and seventy four yards from
scrimmage last year for a team that had
a work-in-progress passing game from
nick foles to a rookie 6th rounder and
then back to foals and then back to the
rookie and threw it all for a net had
his best season in football really since
his freshman year at LSU where we all
were like hey Leonard fournette maybe
the first overall pick in the draft at
some point so the guy's got skills the
guy's got talent now Ian Rapoport
reported earlier today the jaguars are
having a fun time having a hard time
finding any interest in the guy and you
know who knows maybe at some point the
jaguars are gonna have to pay a little
bit of his salary to get him off the
roster or maybe they're just gonna have
to take a you know a sixth or
seventh-round pick but they want to
avoid that 4.1 million and they want to
move on it's just going to be hard for
them to get value apparently but I don't
know I like it you know the Steelers are
the kind of team where if it came out
the students for Leonard fournette we
would say like I said when they got
making Fitzpatrick last year during the
season damn I wish I would have thought
of that ahead of time cuz it makes sense
I mean doesn't it make sense to see
Leonard fournette in black and gold
doing the Jerome Bettis thing and just
counted between the tackles and given
Ben Roethlisberger the help that he
doesn't have now that lay beyond bells
gone no
about it no question and James Connor
there too in the role that he was in
with with with Belle right just put I
guess put fournette in the bell cow role
right and let let Connor get in there in
a way that he has not been able to stay
healthy that that makes such sense to
the point where why the hell would it
happen right you know and you know I
suggested yesterday the chief should be
at the front of the line and a lot of
cheese fans went crazy it's like their
leading rusher last year was Damian
Williams with 498 yards he got 90 of
those yards on one play against the
Vikings you take that play away he had
408 yards for a team that has such a
great passing offense that the running
Lane should be wide open for a running
back they spent 3 million on LeSean
McCoy he didn't have 500 rushing yards
last year so if you could have spent 3
million on LeSean 4.1 million on for net
and you put him with the honey badger
Tyrann Mathieu grew up in the same
neighborhood in New Orleans if Leonard
pur Nets a pain in the butt in
Jacksonville he's gonna be the opposite
of it if he's got Tyron Matthews
influence all the time and just think
about that Chiefs offense if you put a
high end tailback in there a guy who's
capable of doing what Fortinet did last
year I mean you may just want to hand
him the trophy and not even bother with
the season right I guess we do need to
see it makes total sense I mean do we do
need to see what happens in the draft
all the Mocs that I see have DeAndre
Swift potentially falling to the Chiefs
at 32 and then there's of course all the
trades that might happen with people
that you know 32 is usually that spot
where somebody trades back in for a
fifth year of control of somebody like
say Lamar Jackson or Teddy Bridgewater
like we've seen in previous drafts Mike
Florio here on the Rich Eisen show what
about Odell we didn't we didn't hit that
is that you said you you said for net
was real does that mean Odell is not in
terms we don't we don't know because
again like like we talked about earlier
they're never gonna come out and tell us
the truth if it is the truth because the
last thing the Browns need is to have
Odell Beckham jr. thinking that they
were or are considering moving him and
when the report came out last week from
workman losses to WFAN that struck me as
you know what it's one of those weird
curveball reports rich where you're like
well where the hell did this come from
this person doesn't break news to me I
find that as being more credible because
that guy's got one swing oh right if I
screw something up if Mort screws
something up if chef D screws something
up if anybody who does it for a living
screw something up you're right back on
the horse the next day and you're gonna
be reporting something accurate that
inevitably will make people forget about
the one you screwed up but if you're
just going to swing the bat one time you
better hit the ball so I think and based
on some of the stuff I did to try to put
meat on the bone I tend to think that
maybe there was something there that
didn't go anywhere
and now the Browns are trying their
damndest to just get the toothpaste back
in the tube because the last thing they
want is Odell Beckham jr. to feel like
his team doesn't love him the way that
it should and that his team was
considering trading him and maybe Odell
is going to be the one who starts saying
hey I'd like to be traded to this team
or that team I mean he's definitely
wanted to play for the Patriots in the
past now Tom Brady's not there so he may
not feel that way but I think that if
there was anything with the talk it's
not a surprise at all that they will
shout from the rooftops now that it's
over and that it's apparently done that
that there was never anything to it
because they have to deal with Odell
going forward a few more minutes left
with Mike Florio Pro Football Talk Pro
Football Talk calm for a PFT p.m.
podcast that I'll be appearing later on
so I guess it'll be PFT p.m. podcast
with Rich Eisen jobar on chase young
later on that you can you can take that
all in on you you can you can promote it
however you wish to 36 font rich I thank
you then we use nine point four borrow
and point four young you know that's
respectful and I appreciate that so the
trade up trade down 72 hours before the
draft most likely to trade up most
likely to trade down would be filling my
tray down because they always distress
right they always do that's right like
every year the John Schneider has been
the GM they found a way to trade down
trade up I really don't know I mean
there's been talk and Peter Kings got a
great mock draft in football morning in
America where the Chiefs maybe trade up
to get Henry rugs the receiver from
Alabama
the Patriots maybe trade up to get to a
if and when he slides out of the top ten
maybe the Patriots are the ones that are
putting out the rumors it he's going to
slide out of the top sense so they can
go up and get their their new
quarterback but to trade up you know the
foul
have done it before and here's the thing
the falcons have done it before when
they were rumored to be trying to do it
so whenever there's a rumour that the
Falcons are thinking about trading up I
take it seriously because for whatever
reason Thomas Dimitrov strategically has
no problem with getting the word out
that he's looking to trade up because
maybe that's the way to eventually find
someone who'll say yes when you've made
sure everybody knows that you're
thinking about trade enough so I think
Peters said that they're looking to
trade up to get a corner so I guess if I
had if I had to pick one I'd say the
Falcons because they wouldn't try to
hide it they just go ahead and make sure
everybody is aware of it and then just
touching on the Patriots I mean shoot we
can spend between now and forever trying
to read tea leaves with Bill Belichick
the sense that he will not go into 2020
with this quarterback room is currently
constituted it seems to be a prevalent
one where do you stand on this Mike
Florio well when I hear Devin McCourty
and Stephane Gilmore and Matthew Slater
who's currently now the longest tenured
Patriot since Stephen Gostkowski is not
coming back they all praise Jared
Stidham what he did at practice what he
did to help make that defense as good as
it was last year challenging him every
single day it's hard for me not to think
that there's a sufficient level of
comfort within the organization that
Stidham can be the guy twenty years
almost after Tom Brady got the reins as
a second year guy
Stidham may be the guy who gets the
reins now look it saw it all maybe part
of an elaborate effort to keep us all
confused as to what they're thinking
about doing during the draft and I would
expect him to draft a quarterback at
some point during this process but the
idea of trading up to get TOA or or
making a big swing in round one at a guy
who would instantly become the starter I
just I have a hard time processing it
and accepting it but you know that just
shows the genius of Bill Belichick
because you never know what the guy's
gonna do and I think he likes it that
way okay and then the the final I guess
quarterback piece unless there's another
do you think there's a fifth after
Jordan love and let's take it starting
first what Jordan love where he may wind
up and who might be that fifth
quarterback sneaking in yeah look I I
don't I don't know that we're gonna get
five or even four in the first round
a lot of people and again who knows
who's put it out there and who knows
who's trying to get Jordan love to slide
but when you mentioned earlier rich the
possibility of someone trading back into
32 and and as you remember perfectly the
teddy bridgewater moved the Lamar
Jackson move
maybe that's the Jordan love spot right
he makes it all the way for round one
and then and then there it is at number
32 somebody calls the Chiefs and says
alright we've got an offer for you and
we're gonna grab Jordan love and we're
gonna control him for the next five
years so I to me that's a very
intriguing spot okay Mike appreciate the
time thanks for the call I will chat
with you later today I will be zooming
in for those scoring at home from the
right side of my desk and and then you
know I have just so you know I've got
books behind me haven't read a single
one of them in a very long time but it
makes me look like I'm well-read and
that's the way I roll because you know
all of our colleagues have been rolling
that way from there one of the things
about this pandemic that has been
fascinating any cable news channel any
sports channel you get to see those
backgrounds and you get to try to
psychoanalyze the person based upon
everything that's behind them as it's
it's been like an unexpected like I
never thought I'd have this access into
someone's home before and see their
choices but I'll be ready to scrutinize
your choices yes I'll have a photograph
of me with my kids behind me because I
want to give off the impression and
father of the year and then all these
books they haven't read to make it seem
like I'm well-read I'm just you know I'm
just putting it all out there but that's
where I'll be zooming with you later on
I look forward to it
well you will see me with a guitar
behind me that I can't play is that
right
what guitar is that what is that iíve
got some guitars hanging on the wall I
do I do these down in my barn and the
guitars are there for the ambience at
one point I tried to play them but then
I realized it's it's either too late to
develop the skills or I never had the
skills in the first place so they just
hang there and look good they give me
street cred and make it look like I
actually know what I'm doing I I know
how to hang them on the wall that's what
I know how are you scribbling on them to
make it seem like that they're a
world-famous rocker to make it seem like
you're you're you're connected in that
way usually actually and this is the
God's honest truth
a friend of mine brought over an
autographed guitar from Alabama whenever
they had their their final tour so
that's one of the four I was never a big
Alabama fan but there is a signed guitar
hanging on the wall from Alabama there
you go
Mike we'll chat later on I appreciate
this call spirit you got it's Mike
Florio Pro fat pro football talk on
Twitter hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here